l'udaf
autour de la truffe ou pas
le 'pipeline' sol mais c'est pas mal ça
après sur le bateau rencontre en passant
par exemple là dedans et ça c'est
intéressant pour la ville
alors passez plus bas si près du bateau
le tasucu doit débattre d'abord
la bonne foi je suis pour tout l'inversé
n'a pas varié hervé
pétroliers selon mme rieutort pathos
bizarre
après tout rien
je
sais combien d'espèces
concours
selon ce qu'on veut pas des trucs
industrielle que la
cdc coeur mais parle toute avancée pour
l'instant tout est ronde et urgents en
fait alors que je coupe un peu l'élan
qu'elle coupe tout le temps de coupure
était considéré comme un tout et pour
tout que tu t'avances notre part je
collectionne que je n'ai pas du tout
peur
en laissant des issues de l'accord
nous nous associons les scores les sols
on l'avait cependant la côte
en fait c'est beau fort
les produits de père en
france on en est loin de l'être qu'elle
agisse au trabendo
ses connaissances entre deux ombres
très flou
naufrage après
l'accord de cotonou des bois
la police nous n'ayons un peu
pour l'axé d'errance
on trouvera la gauche apprend rien le la
bulle regard peur de cette végétation
passait à gauche dans les camps où est
nichée canche et
on défend ses droits
je suis dans l'écran jour des français
voilà la fleur
vous prenez beaucoup de supporters
m